tenemos fx es igual a 7 x 5 y gtx es
igual a x al cubo 4x nos piden
determinar
efe por g evaluada en x efe porque es
una nueva función y lo que tenemos que
saber es cómo está definida y
básicamente consiste en multiplicar
ambas funciones
efe es decir f por gd x es igual a efe
de x x gx x gdx y entonces podemos
sustituir estas expresiones y continuar
desarrollando déjame indicar las esta de
acá es f x en color verde en color
morado voy a poner gdx y entonces esto
de aquí es igual a es igual a 7 x 5 7 x
5 x x al cubo más 4 x multiplicado sin
ese no es el color x x al cubo más 4 x
muy bien entonces aquí tenemos dos
binomios multiplicándose para
desarrollar esta expresión puedes
utilizar
boyle a mí la verdad no me gusta porque
se nos olvida que está en el fondo en el
fondo para multiplicar estas expresiones
se utiliza la ley distributiva así que
voy a realizar la multiplicación
pensando en la ley distributiva entonces
esto de aquí es igual a la forma en la
cual lo voy a pensar es que este 7x
menos 5 se va a distribuir en cada uno
de estos dos términos entonces me
quedaría 7 x menos 5 x x al cubo x x al
cubo más 7 x menos 5 7 x menos 5 x 4 x x
4x y ahora simplemente tenemos que
volver a utilizar la ley distributiva
ahora éste se distribuye acá y acá es un
poco raro ver las distribuciones por la
derecha pero es exactamente la misma
cosa porque este x al cubo bien podría
estar a la izquierda en fin esto de aquí
nos da igual y vamos a hacer la
multiplicación x al cubo por 7 x es 7
x a la cuarta x al cubo por menos 5 es
menos 5 x cúbica más 4 x x 7 x 7 x 4 es
28 x x x de este x cuadrada y menos 5 x
4 es menos 20 menos 20 y aquí hay una
equis y me parece que ya no se puede
simplificar nada x a la cuarta x al cubo
x al cuadrado x ok entonces esta de aquí
ya es la expresión simplificada para f
por g de x y simplemente debemos de
recordar que f x gtx es la función que
se obtiene al multiplicar
efe con g